mantas skin like shark skin is made up  of these rough sandpaper identicals so  it's not a nice smooth surface like a  whale and what that means we think is  that the suction cups aren't able to  maintain that seal so we tried to find a  sealant something in town here in yellow  Appa that we could use and there was  nothing really viscous enough that it  would stay on the suction cup in the  water while we were swimming over the  Manta and the only thing that would  really stay put was creamy peanut butter  and so we gave that a go we put a nice  big slop on the suction cup went down  and the first one that we put it on  doubled our previous retention time so  by using peanut butter we were able to  get six hour deployments on the mantas  nothing that we can find seems to work  better than peanut butter and that's the  reason that peanut butter has become a  crucial part of our toolkit  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  you